the Joe Rogan experience now the gimbal
video shows a different kind of thing
yes how many different kinds of things
are you aware of well those are ours too
if you look at the go-fast it kind of
looks like a tic-tac so you could say
those two are the same yeah I I think
there's other stuff out there you know
and sometimes it's not that the you got
a look at where do you obtain the video
it's just like intelligence you know and
I'll use because I didn't know you got
that picture of Pablo out there you know
and there was the guy Tom Cruise made
the movie about him what's his name
Louisiana due to his flying the drugs
for Pablo in and out very seal Barry
seal you know hey it was all great until
Regan posted that picture that they had
the cameras inside the cargo plane and
then Pablo puts the dagger but the only
place that picture came from is Barry
seals airplane you know and then now
Barry seals a dead man so you got a
watch when you release cuz you go hey we
got this video but it was taken
someplace we probably weren't supposed
to be or how did they get that video
right like I'll look the video of the
tic-tac video that thing first came out
is kind of funny the guy that was in my
backseat had sent me an email and this
is about probably 2008 so I was retired
and he sent me this video guys say
skipper's this look familiar
and it was on strange land calm but not
suitable for work just say that but I
look and then next thing you know it's
on YouTube so when I would tell this
story to my friends I would go I'd send
them a link to the YouTube video and
this is years before the New York Times
article and then when they did the
unofficial official report the you the
video was taken down off of YouTube and
you know it kind of puzzled me like
why'd you take the video down and I told
the guys when they did the unofficial
official products that what you really
need to look at is how did this thing
come off of a classified Drive system on
an aircraft carrier and end up on
strange land calm in YouTube because at
the time the videos were classified
secret and and that's not because it was
a UFO it's the the 80 flare video what
they did not want that release so you'd
see it on CNN they blocked out all the
performance stuff what the airplane was
actually doing in this case you know the
one you see it's 250 knots of the
autopilot on so it's not that big of a
deal but you know Jeremy how many
different types of vehicles are you
aware of
that I've been reported credible reports
for decades hundreds of different shapes
even Lazar himself said he saw you know
nine different styles all working off
the same propulsion system the tic-tock
shape you know vehicle that that goes
back in history some people say cigar
shaped you know big ships small ships we
you know they're all different kinds I
think it's important to state though
there are other funded government-funded
UFO programs it's a misnomer actually
that a tip was the recipient of the
twenty two million dollars it was
actually harry reid created a program
called awesome awesome was the sole
beneficiary of that twenty two million
new york times got it wrong and then
what happened is a tip was a different
funded program to study military
encounters with UFOs aw snap was created
because of skinwalker ranch a government
program to study UFOs and associated
phenomenon a tip and Allsop communicated
and shared information but they were
independently funded so the twenty two
million dollars was for OSAP and then a
tip had its own sources and then they
did collaborate to UFO programs there
are more that I think we're gonna learn
about so the different shapes that bob
lazar saw there was nine different
shapes that he saw yes I saw there's
only one up close yeah and none of them
were like to tic-tac not specifically
however that's not an uncommon if you go
back in history of like military
sightings of craft going maybe over
twenty thousand miles an hour the
tic-tock is a shape they have triangles
they have ones that look like rectangles
the thing that is common with all of
them is the non reactionary propulsion
system I think even commander flavor
said the thing noticed him was words he
first said to me and and kind of went
towards him with its nose but it could
move in any direction right I mean it
could just move that will however it was
when we first thought it was just
basically you never turned it was just
going left right you know kind of doing
this she probably doesn't matter and
then it became aware because it turned
and it actually mirrored what I was
doing I when I was coming down it came
up and you know so it was obviously knew
we were there and I don't know if it was
picking up you know energy coming off
the airplane or what you know I do know
that when they tried to lock it it
actively
you know it jammed a radar made it
pretty much useless and you know Chad
was pretty good about kicking it over
and grabbing that video so it's pretty
wild it's a big deal to actively jam a
radar virus you know yeah it's um you
know whenever someone tells you an
awesome story it's great to hear but god
I wish I saw it myself you know yes but
you got thing that's yeah you're like
you're telling me and I'm like wow I'm
listening I'm trying to imagine I'm
putting it in my head on them I'm
visualizing it but damn I wish I could
see it
[Applause]